[Music]
hello this is - today I'm gonna talk a
bit about my first classical game as
world champion it was played in the
sewage tournament against Boris Gelfand
I'm playing white and from a fianchetto
Greenfeld doesn't look like I have all
that much it's a symmetrical position
and I do have a slight space advantage
in the sense that I have c4 against c6
but that's not much the b3 pawn may be
weak it may be a strength strengthening
in the center opening the a file but
it's it's it's not at all clear whether
whether that is at this point in time it
was very important to think about
possible candidate moves and I think
this is one of those positions which is
surprisingly concrete normally you again
you would think that the position is
fairly dull the Queen's have been
exchanged it's symmetrical but if you
look long enough you can see that there
are certain things that like wants to
achieve that white wants to achieve and
that a lot of things can still happen so
at this point I was thinking that if
black were to move he would probably
take on t2 then I would take back with
the bishop since 92 with hanging the
pawn on d4 and he would probably play
Bishop to e4 with an extremely solid
position which I don't think that I
would be able to to break down so my
next move came to me very very naturally
that I played ìiî ìiî is always a move
you're a little bit wary of making when
you've got the bishop on f4 since now it
got it's got no escape squares backwards
but I felt that concretely I could I
could do it and that was really all it
was was about no considerations of
whether it may look dangerous and I'm
not sure I should do it it was it was
just a case of I feel like III is
positionally desirable and if I don't
see any way the bishop on f4 is it's
gonna be in trouble then I'm gonna plate
now he played the move Knight to a6 once
again now Knight 62 would be quite
pointless because of 92 attacking the
pawn on d5 and I think in this case
releasing the tension favorably for me
so he played 96 and this was the main
move that I was looking at when I was
playing that when I was thinking about
III because now it's not that easy to to
see what what is going to do Black has a
very clear plan of putting the night and
before exploiting that we can square
that this double pawn has created and
and also the there's a square on d3
which has been created by my phone first
to e3 but now that I've found some
stability on on d4 with with III and his
pawn is no longer protected on d5
I started to think that it would be
really really really nice if the
diagonal could be Oh
for this bishop on g2 and it could at
some point take the pawn on d5 which
would ruin his ruin his entire queenside
construction so what I did is I took on
d5 taken t5 and I went G for underlining
the the importance of thinking
concretely and finding candidates moves
in in this sort of situations maybe
[Music]
maybe the move g4 never crosses your
mind but if it does I'm sure for a lot
of you you kind of get it out of your
mind
because the complications that follow
transform a game that threatened to be
quite dull into something very concrete
and I think quite exciting so what
happened is he took the pawn on g4 once
again not not so easy to find a way to
to keep the solidity of his position
here if he takes on t2 I take back and
he has to put this the bishop on this
very awkward Square on on e6 now I got
several ideas first one that comes to my
mind is to play Knight to be one the
knight will later go to b3 once again on
underlying the the importance of these
candidate moves if you don't look at you
may not look at to move an IP one at all
but once you look at it you understand
that it's the right move positionally
the not from c3 blocks the the C file
for his rooks and will keep the pressure
on d5 for a long time since this bishop
on e6 doesn't really it's not really
possible for it to move and he will not
be able to solidify his position
by playing e6 the way that I've played
eats me so it's simply a very pleasant
position for whites so he sort of has to
take the challenge is said and take the
pawn I take de 492 and I remember I
spent a lot of time here on the previous
moves calculating calculating the forest
lines here not so much because I was
unsure of whether this concept was was
correct or not mainly I just found it so
fascinating to to look at these at these
forcing lines and I was just captivated
by them until I realized that I have to
move at some point and this time can be
spent calculating
later on as well anyway what he did I'm
just going to show a few further moves
he played f5 I went f3 he went if he
goes yeah three I take back with the
night you can see for instance if black
takes the night I take with the bishop
and this Bishop air is now extremely
powerful pointing against his coincide
the bottom b7 will fall the pawn on a
seven will fall and my bishops ruled the
board if he does not take on f3 I have
ideas like Knight to e5 with the same
sort of ideas opening up for for both
bishops and also Knight to g5 then later
on Bishop d5 check or knight c6 could
could wreak some havoc so he decided
quite cleverly to throw in the move e5
instead now he makes sure that in the
case
of d5 has happened EF 396 f3 that the
night is not coming to e5 and this is
also one of those cases where every
single one of my piece pawns are doubled
or isolated and yet it seems that every
time you have a bunch of isolated and
doubled pawns you have a lot of activity
and squares for the pieces right now for
instance the pawn on e3 is covering the
important d4 square making d4 a very
attractive post for for the night the
pawn on e5 it's not clear whether it's a
strength or weakness or I say we can see
in the game one more move rook to e8
threatening Bishop s 3 followed by
Bishop to e5 block would be very much ok
here if the pawn was in a2 but with the
pollen on b3 I have the move rook to a5
keeping up the pressure protecting
protecting e5 though the position is
very I'm gonna leave it here the
position is still very complicated but
eventually I prevailed after an exciting
fights and this is really all you need
to know how the position transformed
from a pretty dull one where it seemed
that it was destined to be a draw till
one where everything everything is
possible and for more examples like this
of a positional play of dynamic play of
candidate moves talking about ideas
calculation all of these things you can
find on the Magnus trainer and even
better explain then I just
[Music]